Welcome back.
Now, while the glass ceiling
may have been shattered
last night,
hearts are still shattering
over Michelle Obama's
speech from Monday.
I wake up every morning in a
house that was built by slaves.
And I watch my daughters,
two beautiful, intelligent,
black young women,
playing with their dogs
on the White House lawn.
(sniffling)
I'm not crying.
I'm just allergic.
Well, this speech wasn't just
a reflection of her time
as first lady.
It spoke to how far
we've come as a nation,
but Bill O'Reilly thought
he should make a clarification
on a key racial issue.
Michelle Obama is essentially
correct in citing slaves
as builders of the White House,
but there were others working
as well.
Slaves that worked there were
well fed and had decent lodgings
provided by the government.
(sputters)
Wh...?
Your takeaway about slavery
is that they were well fed?
Ooh.
(in Southern accent):
Thank you, Massa O'Reilly,
for-for-for clarifying me
about slavery.
-(applause, cheering)
-I appreciate that.
Oh, oh, you know what, sir?
If'n I could read,
I sure would wants to read
your book about killing Lincoln.
Course I ain't allowed to read,
seeing as I'm a slave and all,
but sounds to me like he did
the wrong thing
by freeing them slaves.
How you gonna free...
(laughing):
how you gonna free people
with a full belly?
See, my slave bit is starting
to wear off already.
Now, I don't know what's worse,
that Bill O'Reilly Fox-splained
slavery or that people all over
the Internet needed him to.
For more, we turn
to nightly show contributor
Franchesca Ramsey
with another installment
of #HashItOut.
(cheering and applause)
Thanks, Larry.
So, apparently, some people
are upset that black people
are in the White House
and that some black people
built the White House.
Check out some of these Tweets.
"Fact check: The White House
was not built by slaves.
Only one third of the workers
were slaves."
Fact check: Putting "fact check"
in front of a bull(bleep) quote,
doesn't make it a fact.
(whooping and applause)
And if only one-third
of the workers were slaves,
that means the White House
was built by slaves.
(cheers and applause)
That just means only two-thirds
of the workers
got to go home at night.
That's how fractions work.
But maybe you stopped paying
attention to fractions
after the three-fifths
compromise.
(applause, cheering)
"Slaves didn't build
the White House,
carpenters did."
This is going to blow your mind.
Some of the slaves
were also carpenters.
Just like Bill O'Reilly
can be a TV personality
and a condescending asshole.
(cheers and applause)
"The White House
was not built solely,
or even primarily by slaves
who were paid for work."
First of all,
is that a Dr. Evil meme?
This meme is old enough to vote.
Not solely built by slaves?
Can please get out of here
with this #AllJobsMatter
(bleep)?
But I get it.
You do these mental gymnastics
because it's uncomfortable
to acknowledge this country
was built in part by slaves,
and that we benefit
from their work.
But what else do you think
they were doing?
"We Shall Overcome" isn't a song
about how hard it is
to play the banjo.
And the worst part,
if you hadn't been so caught up
on the word "slavery,"
you would have realized
that Michelle Obama
was saying something positive.
Yes, the White House
was built by slaves,
which is why it's such
a big deal
that we have a black president.
If you have a problem with this,
then I'm going to guess it only
is because of who is saying it,
so let me try and put this into
words that you can understand.
(with accent):
"I wake up every morning...
(cheers and applause)
...in a house that
was built by slaves."
Is that better?
No, it's not better!
Franchesca Ramsey, everybody!
We'll be right back.